[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I am very pleased
to introduce and host
one of my oldest and closest
friends, Mike Hoefflinger.
Mike and I met at Intel
in the summer of 1997.
He was working on
Intel marketing.
I was right out of
business school.
And since then, he's
had a fabulous career,
both at Intel and at Facebook.
He left Intel
after having served
as Andy Groves' Chief of Staff
for, I believe, three years--
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Couple years.
SPEAKER: --which,
within Intel culture,
is essentially a clear signal of
succession, in terms of people
they are grooming to
eventually run the company.
And if you look at historically
who have been Intel CEOs,
several have been Andy's chief
of staff, as it turns out.
And then he left.
He left for Facebook and
has gone on to work there.
He worked out for six years?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER:
Yeah, 6 and 1/2 years.
SPEAKER: And then left, I think,
last year and has since written
the book "Becoming Facebook."
And that would be a
great way to get him
in front of friends and
colleagues at Google,
have him share some
of his thoughts
on working at Intel, Andy
Grove, working for Zuckerberg,
and working at Facebook.
So Mike, great to have you here.
Thanks for coming.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Thanks
so much for having me.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you very much.
SPEAKER: I know that 2 o'clock
on the Friday before Memorial
Day is a tight schedule.
So thanks, everyone,
for making the time.
So in terms of-- if we
go back to the beginning,
with Intel in
particular, Andy Groves
passed away last March--
kind of one of, in my mind,
one of the defining figures
of global leadership
and management and obviously
technology as well.
Do you think there
are any lessons
that this group and the people
on the video should know,
as it relates to
what Andy's mantra is
or principle that everyone
should really kind
of subscribe to,
or at least think
about when they're looking
for visions or principles?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Definitely.
And I think one of the
aspects of the book
is that we think about
these titans, like Andy.
And literally, they
have single names--
Andy and Steve and
Mark and Larry and Eli.
We call them just by one name,
because we know exactly who
we're talking about.
And they're titans of industry.
And I think we celebrate
them to various degrees,
mythologize them.
And then we go back to
our jobs, and we're like,
well, we can never be like those
people, they're super special,
and I can't be like that.
And I think that's
actually not so true.
If you think back to
Grove, for example,
who clearly put the Silicon
in Silicon Valley-- and I
don't say that just because
I've worked for him.
And obviously that was
a huge loss last year.
But he was maybe the
original, what I call,
clever foolish CEO,
which is someone
who has an idea that's
very, very clever,
but everybody, at the time,
thinks it's totally foolish.
Andy said in the very early
'90s that not only are
we going to go build
microprocessors,
but we're going to actually
market them and make
people care about that.
And that was completely
insane at the time.
And now not only
did that happen,
but we're on to the
next thing already.
And Steve said, we're going
to go make home computers,
when nobody thought that
that was at all possible.
And Larry said that we're going
to organize the information
when everybody thought
that Yahoo was basically
done with that whole topic.
Yahoo was pulling
engineers off of search
by the hundreds when
Larry and Sergey said,
no, no, hang on a second,
we can do that better.
And it's still, to me, amazing
that John Doerr put $20 million
into that back then.
We can talk about the
ping-pong table in Larry
and Sergey's
boardroom in a minute.
And so what can we learn
from them is that, of course,
you have to have vision.
You have to be able to
see around the corner.
You have to be able
to see something
that not everybody else is
seeing, because an idea that's
clever that everybody
thinks is clever
is just a big-ass food fight.
So there is no winning
there, at least not
in a highly leveraged way.
But to me, what
is also important
about these folks is
that they do get credit
for being a visionary.
What they don't get credit for
is that on a day-to-day basis,
they have the will to
move towards that goal.
Everybody thinks Andy is a
genius because he moved Intel
from memories into
microprocessors and then said,
we can make people care about
this, Intel Inside program--
blah, blah, blah.
But he was really a genius
because he got up every morning
and said, are we done yet?
Are we done yet?
How is that going?
And I have to imagine--
I don't know for sure,
but I have to imagine--
Sundar, Larry, Sergey,
your leaders here--
that you feel that way--
that you don't just dream
things but that you go
do them every day.
And I think we can
totally learn from that.
You might not be able to be
Grove or Jobs or Zuckerberg
or Larry or Sundar,
but you can 100%
think about looking
around the corner
and 100% think about
getting to the doing.
SPEAKER: Cool.
And so when I left Intel in
'99, you were, at the time,
Andy's Chief of Staff.
And I think Andy had
began, at your urging,
to kind of do a
round-robin meeting
with prominent start-ups, and
some small, some not so small.
And one of them happened to
be Larry and Sergey at Google
when there was maybe
15, 20, 30 people, which
I think Susan kind of
brokered back in the day.
So can you talk about that kind
of meeting-- how it came to be,
what was the take-away when
you got Larry and Sergey
in their earliest days
in a room with Andy
Grove in the fall of 1999?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Yeah,
that's special stuff.
We were just joking about if
there's interns in the room
and you're 19, 20
years old today,
you were born after
this moment that we're
describing, roughly-ish.
But what Grove was really
good at is he, at that point--
we're talking '99.
He had already basically
been mythologized
as maybe one of the most
important leaders in Silicon
Valley.
He could have
easily assumed that,
whatever I think is right.
But he would spend
a ton of time--
especially this was
dot and dot com.
So Intel really, really
had to figure out
how to get this
internet thing together.
And he was trying
to figure out, who
are these leaders in the
internet space that are legit,
and who are the leaders in the
internet space that are not
so legit?
So we probably visited
50 leaders in the space.
And John Doerr, who's a famous
venture capitalist at Kleiner
Perkins, was, before he
went to Kleiner Perkins,
a relatively big
figure at Intel that
had had a relationship with
Andy Grove at the time.
And of course, it was
John, as we just said,
who put $20 million into Google.
And John had--
I remember this exactly.
This is going to sound
like I'm name-dropping.
But it's an awesome story,
so I'll do it anyway.
So we were on a plane with John.
It was maybe John's plane.
And Andy and I were
going up to Seattle
to visit Jeff Bezos,
which has got to be,
like, the single best
namedropping sentence ever.
And while we were flying up
there, John looks at Andy.
He's like, yeah, you should
talk to these two guys,
I just put $20
million into them.
It's '99.
It's Google.
I'm not 100% sure--
I might have shown Andy Google--
the "I'm lucky" button.
SPEAKER: It was the Pentium
II search I think you did.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Yeah.
And I want to say, maybe you're
the one that told me about it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPEAKER: I'm going to
interrupt this story
to tell you how we got to
Google, because what happened
was Susan and I were working
at Intel at the time.
And Susan said,
I'm leaving to work
with these guys in my garage,
it's going to be a cool gig,
knock yourself out, I'm
going someplace else,
I don't want to join those guys.
So I went to go say hello to
Mike in his cube, which was
fifth floor, important people.
Andy's sitting across the way.
And I said, hey,
let's go to Yahoo
and do a search for Pentium II.
And I did a search
Pentium II in Yahoo.
It was all garbage--
just garbage.
For top 10 results,
all garbage results.
And they said, let's
go to Google.com
and do a search for Pentium II.
I did a search for
Pentium II right
on the Intel.com
Pentium II website.
And that's when the light
bulb went off, definitely
in my head.
It cost me a lot of money,
because I didn't go into Google
after having done that query.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: And
I think we should spend
a lot of time dwelling on that.
SPEAKER: Yeah, of course.
And then Mike kind of saw,
hey, that's kind of cool.
The other prominent
website in the industry
can't even get to
our flagship website.
When you search for
the product, you
go to some
20-something-person company
right on the actual
page you want to go to.
And that's, I
think, kind of what
prompted the intro to--
that's when John mentioned it.
You recognized it.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Exactly right.
And those two things
came together.
And that's exactly what it was.
And the other thing that had
really piqued Grove's interest
at the time is-- because I think
the word was out that Larry
and Sergey were
building on x86--
Intel architecture,
standard microprocessors,
in standard servers,
which now, of course,
we recognize as the
fundamental move that
actually made Cloud possible.
But back then, you
got to remember,
dot and dot com was the
law of the land, basically.
If you were not getting
custom-designed servers,
what the hell were you doing?
Whereas Larry and Sergey,
going back to Stanford
when they were operating under
the desk-- they were putting
their own servers together.
You guys have heard
this story 100 times.
I still remember Larry calling
me up in the years afterwards
and being like, we
cannot get enough CPUs,
can you have your channel
partners get their shit
together, because we're having a
server build party this weekend
and I need 1,000 more.
Like, Larry himself--
and so Andy's like, hmm,
that's fascinating,
because we're
trying to figure out what the
future of Intel microprocessors
was beyond the desktop.
And so I'm like, OK, this
sounds like a great idea.
So we go together with
John and Andy and myself.
And we visit Larry and Sergey.
And they're on the second
floor, above the ice cream
shop, downtown Palo Alto.
Neither of those
things exist anymore.
But it was, I want to say,
20, maximum 30 people.
I think Marissa was
the only woman there.
And we were in what
Larry and Sergey
called their boardroom, which
I think was more a lunch room.
And we were literally,
I shit you not,
having the meeting
at a ping-pong table.
And they were talking
about what the game
plan was for this thing.
SPEAKER: For ping-pong
or the company?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: It's
intertwined, obviously.
And I remember thinking
very distinctly--
because Andy and I, after we
would go to these meetings--
and we would visit other
leaders, like Jeff Bezos.
It was fairly clear
to us that these
are super legitimate
leaders of the future.
This was a totally real thing.
And then we would
visit other leaders,
names not to be shared,
where we're like,
oh, I don't know, man, if
that's going to come together.
But I remember the
two of us absolutely
walking away from that
and feeling like it
was a very, very big deal.
And Andy wanted
to make very sure
that Google and Larry and
Sergey were getting everything
that they needed to build a
massively parallel x86 base
universe that served
you good search results.
SPEAKER: So was it a combination
of roadmap or charisma
or just--
what was it about
the meeting or them
that made you and Andy realize
that even as a 20-person shop,
there's something here?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Yeah.
I think, well, the results spoke
for themselves, like you said.
One of the beauties, of course,
of great internet products
like Google and
Facebook is that there's
zero barrier to trying it.
And if you can have a
great magic moment, which
is fantastic search
results or seeing
your friends in your
news feed, then you
can win, even if you're tiny.
But I think it was
a couple things.
One is Larry and Sergey
believed what we believed,
which is that a standardized
architecture is going
to be way better for scaling
this thing and making it work,
from a cost perspective.
So we felt
strategically aligned.
And I remember the
two of them were
very unaffected, super young.
I'm going to totally make
up-- they were less than 25,
for sure.
But they were totally
unaffected by talking with Andy.
And they were very
balanced with him.
They didn't take
him for granted.
But they also weren't
stunned at his--
he's like the authority in
Silicon Valley at the time.
So it just felt
extremely authentic.
And they were like, this is
what we're going to go build,
we're very confident about it.
And we're like, I get it.
SPEAKER: Cool.
So when you look at having had
a lot of experience with Andy
and also a lot of experience
with Mark at Facebook,
what linearities exist
between their styles,
their perspective, how
they approach the business,
how they want to
grow the business,
how they disrupt the business?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: I
had a chance in 2009,
when I started
working at Facebook,
to tell Andy that
I was there now,
to tell Mark that I
had worked for Andy,
and whether the two of them
would be interested in meeting.
And they said, yes.
And I had a chance to sit in
on that lunch, which you have
to kind of paint this picture.
Andy is in his 70s.
Andy is in his early 20s.
They're separated by 50 years--
two generations-- not just two
generations in age, but also
two generations in technology.
Andy was CPU, and then
came the internet,
and then came, if you
will, Mark and mobile.
I'm not equating those
two, necessarily.
And yet, one thing that's
amazing about Mark--
and I bet you feel this
from Larry, Sergey, Sundar,
and much of people
here as well--
is, as much as you have
a vision for how things
need to move forward,
there is a respect
for the past in Silicon Valley.
There's an interest to
learn from the past.
So Zuck was
absolutely a disciple
of Grove's kind of management
Bible "Only the Paranoid
Survive."
And so they were trying to
dial each other a little bit.
Andy was trying to figure out
if Zuck was the real deal.
And Zuck was trying to
kind of deal with the fact
that Andy had jumped off
the page of this book,
and he had a chance
to chat with him now.
And they were kind of circling
each other a little bit.
And then Grove
went for the gusto
and said, why did you pass up
the billion dollars from Yahoo?
And Zuck was able to read that
not as an offensive question
but as a real question.
And he kind of thought
about it a little bit.
And he said, look, I just
felt really confident
that we could be
much, much bigger
than what Yahoo we
thought we could be.
And Andy really
understood in that moment
that Mark was like him.
You remember what I said
about Andy-- right--
the willpower to get up tomorrow
morning and ask yourself,
are we done yet, how are
we doing on that thing--
that Mark hadn't just
seen around the corner,
but had the willpower
to go build this thing.
And that, to me, was amazing to
see it across two generations--
that you had this echo of
this willpower-ey thing
that I had seen in
Andy that I felt
was so important, actually,
that Mark has that as well.
And it completely
doesn't matter which
epoch of Silicon
Valley you are or where
in the pecking order of
Silicon Valley you are.
That's the defining thing
to me of Silicon Valley--
the doing never gets in
the way of the talking.
And if you ever find yourself at
a room, either at your company
or at some other company,
where the talking is
getting in the way of the
doing, run to the hills.
Code settles arguments.
I don't want to pretend
that I know your culture.
But I think this
is what it feels
like here, because I know
that's what it feels like there.
SPEAKER: On that topic
of when the talking gets
in the way of doing,
and I'll say this--
how do you stop it?
When you actually
encounter it in a meeting
and it's not so easy to run
for the hills, so to speak,
how do you intervene?
What can you do to kind of get
in the way of that trajectory?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Well, what
I think internet businesses
like us--
what's so amazing is that
we really, if we want to,
we can really pay
very close attention
to the people that
are using our stuff.
And that's the one thing
you can never escape.
People either like your stuff,
or they don't like your stuff.
And tomorrow, they like your
stuff better than they did
today, or they don't.
And you had an idea, and
you put it in front of them.
And they either sparked
to it, or they didn't.
Or you're observing
them do stuff that's
using the product in a way
that you hadn't intended,
and it gives you a
chance to adjust.
So I think us, as businesses--
imagine you're Ford where
it's very difficult, because--
I'm totally making up a name.
I'm not trying to pick on Ford.
But they have a
channel structure,
and Dearborn can be pretty far
removed from a person in Idaho
who's using their F-150.
It's a little difficult
to know, do they
love this version of
the F-150 or don't they?
Whereas we-- this is not
a religious question.
Either people like your thing
more today than they did
yesterday, or they don't.
And we should keep
building stuff.
For a second, I'll pick on Wave.
And then I'll go pick
on a Facebook thing.
SPEAKER: Meaning the early
Google social products?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Yeah,
whatever you want to call it,
which, by the way,
was it's problem.
I'm sorry.
And by the way, of course--
and unfortunately, I
forgot his name now.
He built Wave here and
then went to work with--
AUDIENCE: Verizon Center.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Yes, exactly.
He went to work with
Mark on Graph Search.
Because you have to
a million percent
applaud him for building
it and, at the same time,
a million percent applaud you
for shutting it down, exactly
the same way that Zuckerberg
leaned in like crazy on Google
Home, which was this
little Android replacement
doohickey, which is
people are finally like,
this is too much Facebook.
I like Facebook, but I'd like
it to not take over my phone.
And so they launched it--
massive fanfare, CEO
of HTC, CEO of AT&T--
and then had to shut it down,
because it just wasn't working.
And that's exactly
what we should do.
We should a million percent
throw it down the field.
And when it doesn't work,
we should stop and move
on to the next thing,
because we know.
There is no religious argument.
People either like your stuff,
or they don't like your stuff.
We have all the numbers.
SPEAKER: I'm
wondering if there's
a way-- if you can't invest
everything in throwing down
the field, how do you
self-select the ones that you
think have the highest
probability of actually meeting
success in a smaller company
environment where you just
can't afford to do everything
at once, at the same time?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Yeah.
And you have to be brutal
about that, for sure.
And of course,
everybody will say,
you've got to make a decision
with less than 100% certainty.
So you got to do two things.
The reason every
one of you is here
is because you have a
point of view about stuff.
That's why Google hired you.
And so you've got to lean
into your point of view.
I believe x.
I believe the next thing
that we could do is x.
And you got to lean into that.
The people around you
have to lean into that.
You have to speak up.
Your leaders have to listen.
So you have to have a point of
view about what might be next,
because there's no guarantees.
If there was some guarantee,
then a couple of women in
[INAUDIBLE] would
have built it already.
I was going to say
a couple of dudes,
but isn't that the problem
in Silicon Valley today.
And then I think
you just have to go.
You have to have
a point of view.
You have to allow
the data that you've
experienced in your
life, whether you
have spent all of your career
here or somewhere else,
to inform you.
And then you have to make a bet.
And how you make
that bet, by the way,
completely decides your future.
And I'm taking execution
for granted there
for a second, which is
like, in good companies,
you should be able to do that.
So your ability to come
up with the next idea
faster than the other
guy and build that thing
is defining, because
if you can put
a magic moment in front of
somebody before somebody else,
you win.
SPEAKER: So in terms of your
transition out of Intel,
you were on a great
career path, obviously.
What pulled you out?
How was Facebook, as a
smaller company today,
at the time, able to
essentially extract you--
who has had a clear path, a
clear future, a clear great
future at Intel--
out of that company
into something which was much
more speculative at the time?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Yeah.
The morning I told
my boss at Intel
that I was moving to Facebook,
she told me I made VP.
And this was the fall of 2008.
The economy is shit--
like, super not good.
And I'm leaving Intel, which
is an annuity, basically.
It's funny.
At the time, I don't
remember feeling that panic.
I should have clearly
been panicked.
Phenomenal company-- super
phenomenal company, Intel,
just to be very clear.
But I was running the
Intel Inside program
at the time, which, together
with the [INAUDIBLE],,
spent $2 billion a year
marketing personal computers.
And the digital advertising
offerings were huge for us.
We had a big
relationship with Google.
We had a burgeoning
relationship with Facebook.
We were beginning to see
that there was something
interesting happening there,
in terms the understanding
that they had of people and the
ability to create demand there
and pairing that with what
we were doing obviously
with search, which
was to convert intent.
And at the time,
I had this feeling
that it would be good
to be at a place that
might be good at mobile.
So this was super
roughly 2008. iPhone
had made clear that smartphones
were not going to be a niche.
And basically, my
whole philosophy was,
if I'm going to not
be an Intel lifer,
I have one time
to make a change,
and this might be a good one.
SPEAKER: And so what were
the criteria for you to say,
this is the one that would--
this is the one you would--
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: I liked
Facebook as a product,
personally.
I used it personally.
I felt that they were in a good
position to do well in mobile.
I didn't know how
right I was about that.
And it was clear
to me, as a person
who spent an enormous
amount of money
in advertising, that this was
going to be a good product.
SPEAKER: OK.
So if we get to the
book, why write the book?
And who's going to
play you in the movie?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: A super,
super old Tom Cruise
will play me in the movie.
And if I'm honest with myself,
an old and overweight Tom
Cruise, which he'll never be.
I don't know how he does that.
So we just simply
hadn't written down,
I think, anything about
Facebook since the movie.
And to me, the seven
years since 2009,
2010 are way, way,
way more interesting--
a 10x in the user
base, 100 in revenue,
four of the top
six communications
products in the world.
I don't care which
side of the truth
you come out on how the
hell Facebook was created
or whether you love
or hate Aaron Sorkin.
The last seven years are
way more interesting.
And nobody had written it down.
And I was there,
so I felt like--
SPEAKER: Meaning, none of
the other books out there
had even did not come close
to having the level of--
MIKE HOEFFLINGER:
Beyond the origin story.
So certainly "Accidental
Billionaires"
was written by Ben Mezrich,
which is the source material.
Ben Mezrich was the
bring the house down, MIT
card counting dude.
That led to a good movie.
And that Mezrich book
was very thinly sourced.
It was basically sourced
only through interviews
with the one other
co-founder of Facebook
that eventually got pushed out.
And then there was the
David Kirkpatrick--
he's the former
"Fortune" journalist who
wrote "Facebook Effect," which
was a very, very good book,
but essentially ended,
more or less, in 2009.
But since then, we haven't
written down anything.
And those stories are,
in my mind, way better.
And I was able to not only
put down what happened,
but how it happened
and what we can learn.
SPEAKER: So what can we learn?
When you look at
"Becoming Facebook,"
the core of the book, if he
had do a Cliff notes for those
who were on the video or--
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Well,
the core of the book,
to the extent that you've leafed
through the table of contents,
is kind of the 10
lessons that I took away
from those seven or eight years
of that unprecedented rise
that they had.
And it starts with
the observation
that I already made, which is,
doing is better than dogma--
finding your inner Zuck.
How the hell do you decide--
forget about whether you
were running a company
or you're building
a product or you're
running a small business.
What is the horizon
of your will to lead?
You've got to be really
clear about that.
And it's fine to build
a feature or a product.
But don't think that you
can go build a mission
and change the world, which
is something the Jeff Bezos
and Steve Jobs of
the world are doing,
and that's going to
take less than 30 years.
And if you don't have willpower
to get up tomorrow morning
and ask yourself
if we're done yet,
then you probably
shouldn't sign up for that.
So I think you learn that.
You learn stuff like
don't disrupt yourself
before somebody else does.
We can touch on
that a little bit.
You learn simple
stuff like how do you
win the talent wars
and this notion
increasingly that we're, I
think, using at more places
than just Facebook in
Silicon Valley, which is,
focus on people's
strengths, practically
ignore their weaknesses.
Just really focus
on matching what
people are interested in
to what you ask them to do.
Get out of the ladder mentality,
because that math doesn't work.
If the only way that
you're engaged at work
is by going up to the
next level of the ladder,
the math doesn't
work, because there's
a third as many spots on
that part of the ladder
as there are at the
level that you are now.
So if you can't keep people
engaged beyond moving them up
a ladder, then you're screwed.
And so even just
subtle things like
that that you don't necessarily
realize outside of the building
are super crucial lessons.
Both Google and
Facebook, in my mind,
are the lenses on
the world today far
and above anything else
in the world, which
is a lesson about if you're
going to build something, add
by subtracting.
Now that we all
have smartphones,
we have a piece of glass in our
pocket connected to everyone,
everything, all the
time, everywhere,
you don't need more shit.
You need less shit that
you really care about.
And if you're building
a product that's
trying to put more shit in
front of you, just forget it.
And so I can give you
topics, and you'll
give me exactly one name
that'll do that for you.
If I said, "information,"
you will say, "Google."
If I say, "people,"
you'll say, "Facebook."
If I say, "places to go
to," you'll say, "Yelp."
TripAdvisor, Uber--
you do the math.
There is only ever one answer
for each of these topics,
because people have
figured out a way
to make things easier for
us rather than harder.
SPEAKER: So let me
ask you, in the book,
you mentioned that Google+ was
doomed three years before it
ever launched.
I can comfortably
say, I knew that it
was doomed five years before
it ever launched [INAUDIBLE]..
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: It wasn't
an idea five years before--
SPEAKER: Well, let me contrast
this with the Google Wave
anecdote where they
should be applauded
1,000 percent for
doing and 1,000 percent
for shutting it down.
If you knew there was going to
be doom three years in advance
of the launch, one, why
would you say it was doomed?
And two, would you have shut
it down then before it even
got ahead of steam to kind
of waste that many resources?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER:
Well, the tricky thing
with these looking back
things is it's always
easy to be 20/20 in hindsight.
But here's why I thought,
looking back on it now,
it was doomed.
I really love the book
called "Crossing the Chasm"
by Geoffrey Moore.
It's not as popular
now as it used
to be maybe 10, 15 years
ago in Silicon Valley.
But it's basically
a book about--
deep scientific
research about how
people adopt new technologies.
And yes, it applies hugely
to consumer technology.
But it also applies
to other things,
like this is how
kindergarten went
from an educational
concept in Germany
to basically take over the
entire world over in 50 years.
This is how new seed
plants in the Midwest
are used by farmers super
rapidly as they come out.
And it's always this notion that
the innovators will pick it up
first, and about 2.5%
of your cohort is that.
Then it will be
the early adopters.
That's about 12 and 1/2%
of your cohort there.
Then comes the
giant chasm that you
have to jump over to get to
the early majority, which
is another, call it, 25%.
Then comes late majority
and then the laggards.
And everything always
happens that way.
And what you have
to realize is, it's
very easy to get the innovators
and the early adopters.
They basically try shit for
the sake of trying shit.
If you can't get them,
you're super screwed.
But the early majority
is really only
when they see all the people
around them using something.
And when it is really,
truly, pragmatically useful,
then they will
jump to go use it.
And if you look at
Facebook in 2009,
they had gotten to the early
majority of internet users
that were using
Facebook, if you would
say the cohort of their target
audience is internet users.
And so if you're going to build
a product that is essentially
like Facebook-- and I don't
think that I'm misstating that
Google+ looked heavily and
behaved heavily like Facebook.
That's not a judgment.
I think that's a
fairly fair conclusion.
If you're going to build
something that is practically
identical, you do
not want to go up
against somebody who is already
on the other side of the chasm.
And that's my issue.
And I think you ask a
great question, which is,
you should have built Wave,
because there was no clear
indicator that it would fail
and it could have been very
interesting, whereas
with Google+,
because of the way
that it was defined--
and a lot of credit to Andy
Hertzfeld, building circles
and all of that.
I get it.
But the way it was
defined, it was
doomed almost
scientifically, if you
believe in the crossing
the chasm philosophy.
And in the book--
to not only basically
throw this thing out
like it was doomed three
years earlier, to me,
the thing you should
have leveraged
was Gmail, which you
tried, because you
put an extension on Gmail.
I forget now what it was called.
But I think that was the tool
that, if you had built it
in a way that wasn't
trying to be totally
identical to Facebook
but was trying to do more
with the network that Gmail
already understood-- all
of the people that
you're sending email to
is the connections that
Facebook was building.
There was an opportunity
there, which,
I think because you slightly
misstepped on the extension
that you had built into
Gmail, which I think you even
got your hand legally slapped--
I forget exactly what went down.
But that would have
been the opportunity,
whereas Google+ was defined--
I don't want to go
too far and actually
take it all the way back to
the leader of that effort who
came from Microsoft.
And I wonder if
that was an issue.
And I don't know
him well enough.
AUDIENCE: It's OK.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER:
But I'm on video,
so I got to be
careful what I say.
Because I think that
is a great question--
there are some things
that you shouldn't start,
because you should know
enough that that is
going to be a very long shot.
And there are some things
that you should start,
even if you don't know
how it's going to go.
SPEAKER: So when you look
at companies like Facebook
in particular, are they
always on the lookout
for self-disruption?
Or is it just something which
they say one day, today we're
going to start, something
has happened in the business,
we have to start looking
to disrupt ourself?
Is it a constant mindset among
the leadership team or even
those who are working on--
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: I
think it's got to be,
because the only thing
you know for sure
from historical records is that
even the greatest technology
companies don't last forever.
You and I are both
not at Intel anymore,
and that's kind of
not an accident.
One of the great miracles
of pulling out of a nosedive
is maybe what Satya
is doing at Microsoft.
But in the Ballmer era--
again, obviously a much
bigger, better executive than I
ever was, so not to pick on him,
but that wasn't going so well.
And Microsoft-- I'm not 100%
sure-- is not out of the woods
yet.
But that's like one of the
all-time great like pull-ups
ever.
But historically--
AUDIENCE: You can't
forget iPhone.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: No.
And by the way, I think--
oh, man, how am I going to put
myself on the record with--
I just can't keep
myself from saying it.
And by the way, I think they
are indeterminant right now.
I think Tim is doing
a phenomenal job
working the numbers, which is
exactly what his history would
suggest.
He was COO of Compaq, had
an incredible reputation
there for managing the numbers.
He is doing that well.
What he is not doing
so well-- and I
don't think I'm going out on
a limb here-- is innovating.
So I hope he's working on some--
AUDIENCE: What about Steve?
I'm talking about
Steve [INAUDIBLE]..
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: And Steve 2.0
was like an all-time comeback.
And it's such a shame that we
didn't get to see Steve 3.0.
That's all I'll say about that.
You have to constantly
be thinking,
how could I disrupt myself?
Because you know
someone somewhere
is doing it, especially
because that's how you grew up.
There was 21 of you
down in Palo Alto.
And you beat the living shit
out of Yahoo, Microsoft,
and everybody.
So if you can do it,
somebody can do it to you.
And so you have to-- if
you're Larry, Sundar, Mark,
Cheryl, you have to believe
that there is somebody who
is out there trying
to beat you, even
if it's Evan Spiegel in LA.
And maybe you think
he's a douche.
Maybe you don't.
How do I put--
this is the worst.
I clearly have to take the
Gary Vaynerchuk approach now,
which is like, I'm
burning this thing down.
Oh, my god.
You'll remember this moment.
SPEAKER: So let's--
I forgot the question
I was going to ask.
Damn you.
That's not good.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: You have
to believe somebody is
going to disrupt you somehow.
SPEAKER: So on
that note also, do
you think Mark has an
unfair advantage in that,
because he has this network?
He has inside information
on what's kind of bubbling.
So with Instagram
or WhatsApp, he
has user data that
no one else has.
So he can say, Instagram
is a bargain at a billion,
even when everyone
thought he overpaid.
And he can say, it's a
bargain at 14 for WhatsApp
when everyone else was
saying at the time,
it sounds like a
ludicrously high number.
But now if you look
back, you say, well,
that was, again, of
all things, a bargain.
So does he have
inside information?
Or is it just kind of
pure being that good?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: He doesn't
have inside information
in the legal form or that word.
But you mentioned Instagram,
for example, which, of course,
at a minimum, was using Facebook
log-in and also, in a way,
actually was
connected to the API.
So Mark, who actually
knew, of course,
Kevin Systrom for years--
the CEO of Instagram--
before that.
They had a personal
relationship.
They had met long before that.
Mark knew much more than
what was publicly available
about Instagram,
which is occasionally
Kevin and Mike would update
on how many users they have--
we've got 10 million-- but
very, very, very occasionally.
But what Mark knew because of
Facebook log-in and other kind
of data that was coming through
the Facebook API completely
legally, because--
SPEAKER: It's their API.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Kevin and
Mike were using the API.
He knew much more
about the degree
of engagement, which
is the kind of almost
daily use, the amount of time.
And he could pattern match.
I've seen this movie
Instagram before.
It might only be 5 million,
10 million, 12 million,
18 million users.
But I've seen this movie before.
It's us.
And at the time, he was
starting to think much bigger
than we realized, which
is Facebook doesn't just
equal Facebook, the
app, which is Facebook
equals the mission of making the
world more open and connected.
And if we could work
together with Kevin--
not like acqui-hire him and
have him build more Facebook--
but bring in
Instagram because it
was another method by which
people connected and shared--
he knew more than
the rest of us did.
And so when Kevin
called him and said,
hey, we're about to take
more money at a $500 million
valuation--
he called him on a Friday
afternoon-- on Monday morning--
Zuck calls him back.
He's says, come
over to my place.
And on Saturday, he's like, I'm
going offering you a billion.
Why don't you come over
here, we will make you
much bigger than you are now.
And Kevin is like, oh, yeah, OK.
And that's just the billion.
And then both of
them proved to have
made an excellent
decision, because Kevin
was able to continue to build
the product that he loved,
that he really cared about.
And he was able to
do it without having
to worry about the massive
infrastructure issues that
are behind that, because
Zuck and the team
were able to help him.
And then, of course,
once you've done that,
then you can get really good--
when you sit down with Jan
Koum, who had built WhatsApp
to 400 million users, you can
look at Jan and you can say,
hey, look how we helped Kevin.
And then Jan can be like,
OK, I get what you're saying.
There is a proof
point that you're
going to leave me alone and
build the thing that I'm
dreaming about and help me
with the stuff that's hard.
This way, Jan didn't have
to worry about monetization.
And so he did know more.
And I think the same
is true for you guys.
I don't know all the data
that you guys are sitting on.
But the world is telling you
every day what it cares about.
So you should have
a better perspective
on pretty much
anything than anyone,
in terms of having data
to back up your instincts
about the future.
SPEAKER: So when
you look at what's
next, from the standpoint of,
what might cause disruption
to a Facebook or a Google, what
is the next big opportunity
that you're seeing when you
look out two, three, four years?
We're on the record saying,
[INAUDIBLE] first company
at this point.
But when you see,
[INAUDIBLE] on your own
experience from
having been at Intel,
having been at Facebook, being
a student of technology--
what would you look at when
you look at a few years down?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Well, you'll
totally remember a thing
that Andy Grove
used to love to say,
which is, market share is
won and lost in transitions.
You remember that?
SPEAKER: Yep.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER:
And he would always
tell the OEMs that to encourage
them to use a new Intel chip.
So ti was clearly a very
self-serving thing to say,
but it's totally true.
And we're in the
best period, to me--
I've been in Silicon
Valley 25 years.
We're in the best period,
which is top of one s-curve--
and you're a room I don't
need to explain s-curves to.
And what I mean by that is
kind of mobile, social, comms,
info-- blah, blah, blah.
We're at the top
of that s-curve.
Everybody done
and done has that.
And we're not yet into the
bend on the next s-curve.
So it feels a little
bit like a lull-- like,
what the hell's going on?
Is anything new happening?
And that, to me, is
my favorite period,
because the shit is
about to get real.
And I think to me,
there's clearly
three categories of stuff--
AI, for sure.
SPEAKER: Yep.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Not
as an end game, but as
a thing that makes the
stuff we build way better.
Everybody's like, AI's coming.
Bullshit.
It's already here.
It makes my searches better.
It makes my news feed better.
It makes my understanding
pictures better.
It will make video better.
And then, of course,
maybe we'll do assistance
on top of all of that.
I'm not 100% sure.
But it's kind of, to the
first order, already here,
but thinking greedy and
to make stuff better,
not robots that run down the
hallway and cook you breakfast.
That, I don't know.
By the way, they're
going to keep
trying to make
intelligent refrigerators.
We just got to stop doing that.
And next thing, I do think--
you were bagging
on this earlier,
so I'll wade into it anyway.
But I do think
augmented reality--
and not as a repla--
everybody is like, oh,
clearly, augmented reality
will replace the phone.
I think that is ridiculous.
What's going to
happen is you're going
to keep this in your pocket.
And it's going to be
your connect and compute.
And you're going to have these,
which are going to be your IO.
And the ability lay information
over your real world--
not in a goofy-ass, there's a
robot down there and I'm going
to shoot it with
my imaginary gun--
not that I'm saying that it's
not good for entertainment.
But I think there is going to
be some very interesting stuff
there, not as a
displacement of mobile,
but I think as a,
if you will, like
a demand regeneration for it.
Now the interesting thing
there is the landlords--
so Android and iOS--
may shift here, unless
the current landlords
do a great job of
shifting to the new.
And then, of course
everybody who
operates on top of what
the landlords are running
needs to pay attention,
because the truth
is, Facebook is running--
has two landlords that really
control their situation, which
is the T's and C's
of the Play Store
and the App Store
control Facebook's world.
You guys could write T's
and C's tomorrow that say,
if you want to
run on Google Play
and you want to do
advertising, you've
got to use Google's native
systems and I take 30%.
You guys could write those
T's and C's tomorrow morning
and Facebook would lose 30% of
their revenue tomorrow night.
Fact.
Now government might come
after you for anti-trust--
not 100% sure.
But the reason
that doesn't happen
is because there's mutual
assured destruction
between Android,
iOS, and Facebook.
There's no way that Google Play
and App Store can fundamentally
fuck with Facebook's
apps, because they're
the most popular shit
on your platform.
And it's a very
delicate balance.
And you've got to
really look at how
the situation of
landlords and tenants
changes as media changes.
It was one of the
fundamental reasons
that Facebook picked up Oculus.
Zuck needs a playing
chip in this chess game
that's going to get played
in augmented reality
in the next two years.
2019, by the way--
Christmas 2019, watch
for massive food
fight in totally legit consumer
AR, triggered by Microsoft.
SPEAKER: OK.
We'll keep an eye out for it.
In terms of top of
the s-curve, if you're
looking at the current adoption
of smartphones globally,
what thought do you give to
the next two billion users?
When you look at the two billion
folks that will never own a TV,
never own a PC,
never own a tablet--
they might own a
feature phone, but they
might own a smartphone.
What opportunities
are presented, if any,
by that segment?
And should it be a focus
for companies like Facebook
and others, given that
monetization prospects are
slim?
Not many advertisers,
not much [INAUDIBLE]----
it's serving a good and
you're getting services out,
but how much of a focus
should it command?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Well,
it's fascinating, I think,
to watch the different players
on this topic right now.
As I say in the
book, at some point,
Zuck had to stand up
in front of his board--
which is cursory, by
the way, because they
don't have control over him--
and say, I want to put a
lot of money for a long time
into something that's going
to be the most difficult thing
that we do with totally
uncertain outcomes that
will monetize, best case, at
1/10 per person as the US.
And the board had to look
at him and be like, yeah,
that sounds fine.
Drones the size of 737s that
weigh as much as a Prius that
stay in the air for 90 days
and get their energy from solar
seems like a great idea.
We should totally put those
up above Africa and India
and Southeast Asia.
And you see that Zuck is
very serious about that.
He really, really does want
to connect the next n billion
people and way beyond--
we live here in LTE land.
And we don't understand
that only 30% of India
is on the internet.
We don't understand that
there is places in Indonesia
that there are days where
they have enough money
to spend on data, and then
there's days and days and days
and days and days where
they don't have enough money
to spend on data.
And we don't know
that there is actually
places where people may have
a phone before they have power
and clean water.
So Zuck is super
serious about this.
My sense, looking at you
guys from the outside,
is that you guys are
super serious about it,
which clearly isn't because
of the monetization potential.
The data is very clear.
It's just like, Zuck has decided
this is important in the world.
And he's going to go do
what he can down that road.
You guys feel to me like--
I feel the same from you guys.
Android, in my mind, is one
of the great fundamentally
enabling technologies
in the space.
And everybody says, Apple gets
all the profits in this space
and Android gets all
the market share.
I think Google Facebook
deserve a ton of credit
for showing that they care
about this way beyond money.
When you look at Apple,
not so clear to me
whether Tim Cook cares about
the next two billion people
that aren't connected.
Not accusing him of not
being, but it's not clear.
It's not evident.
And then you look at
somebody like Evan--
and I hate to pick on
Evan, because he's clearly
building the MTV of right now.
And you have to give
him credit for that.
But Evan has essentially said,
I don't care about India.
I think he might have
literally said that.
But he's very clear
that his strategy is,
I'm never going to grow
as big as Facebook,
I'm going to go for massive
ARPU in the Western world.
That's what Evan has
said, which, by the way,
is a good strategy.
There's no way that he'll
be as big as Facebook,
so you've got to go
deep and do ARPU.
But he has, either by his
action or through his words,
essentially said, I don't
care about the unconnected,
and I actually don't
even care about the lower
percentiles of the connected.
So you just watch the
actions of these companies.
And you see what their
intent in the world is.
And sometimes their
intent is totally related
to revenue and profitability.
And sometimes it totally isn't.
But I do think that
there's so many people
outside of the bubble that
look at Google and Facebook
and just like, oh, my god,
it's not real in my world,
and you guys are all
just about the money.
And you just can't look
at Google and Facebook
in particular and accuse
them, in this case,
of being about the money,
because chasing low-end Android
and connecting the
unconnected is not
a great business right now.
AUDIENCE: So in addition
to vision execution,
how much of a role do you think
luck plays for these luminaries
that you mentioned?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: I think
it's impossible to say
that it doesn't play a role.
Absolutely, you have to be
able to see around a corner.
You have to time it well.
You have to have the guts
to go after something
that other people
think is crazy.
You have to be able to
execute well tomorrow.
I do think you have to get a
little bit lucky, for sure.
You look at Facebook,
for example.
Mark wrote the
Facebook.com in 2004,
totally web-based,
of course, which
is only thing that he really
could build at that time.
And it was 2006 that
we got News Feed, which
was the fundamental
breakthrough, if you will,
of the Facebook user
experience, that they
built because they
saw people pecking
around people's profiles.
And they're like,
oh, my god, we've
got to build one place where
you just see all this stuff,
and then we'll filter
it a little bit.
But even that was the
year before iPhone,
which they probably sold
a couple of million units.
And then they were in just
perfectly beautiful position,
because News Feed itself was
a vertically scrolling column
of bite-sized information
that, looking back on,
is like, it's
perfect for mobile.
You literally couldn't have
invented a better thing
for mobile, except they
did it before mobile.
And so the fact that they
built Facebook in 2004,
then they built
News Feed in 2006,
and then they had this perfect
confluence with mobile--
even Chris Cox, who is an
awesome Chief Product Officer,
would not tell you that he had
that whole thing figured out.
And it was a perfect fit that
came together beautifully
for them.
And even Chris,
Mark, I think, would
say that was a piece
of good fortune.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have any insights
on the tension between
Google as being
the gateway to the
open web and the rise
of these closed-off platforms,
like Facebook, Instagram,
Snapchat, and if you
see any kind of threats
or opportunities
within that space?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: That's
an interesting, actually,
distinction between the two.
The way that I always think--
I think Google and Facebook are
kind of the defining companies
right now, because they simply
are the lenses between us
and our world.
If you know what
you're looking for--
I'm going to oversimplify
a little bit--
if you know what you're
looking for, you go to Google.
If you don't know what you're
looking for-- you kind of just
want to know what the
hell's going on-- you
go to Facebook's products.
That's an oversimplification.
But clearly, head and shoulders
above anybody else, that's
how I think of the two of them.
I think a user in
Chicago who doesn't
sit in rooms like this doesn't
think about open web, closed
web.
I don't think that's a
thing for them, actually.
I think they just
care about stuff
that they want to get done
in their life and people
and things that they care about.
And I think that's
how they think.
I think if we introduce
this notion of,
do you realize Google is open
and Facebook is closed-ish,
they'd be like, I don't
understand what that means.
And so I think you have to
ask yourself-- opportunity
and threat, I think,
is always mostly
what do people care
about, as opposed
to constructs that
we'll invent here,
which are totally relevant.
You sit in rooms.
And you discuss this
kind of strategy.
You have to think about
that kind of stuff.
But I don't think that's
how people actually think.
And so I think
you've got to just
be obsessed about what
people are telling you,
by virtue of what they're
doing with your products, which
is why it's so important
that you try things,
because that allows
people to provide you
with insight about how
they're using those things.
And so I think opportunities
and threats simply come from,
are you giving people
enough opportunity
to tell you what they want?
AUDIENCE: Why hasn't
somebody bought Twitter yet?
SPEAKER: Oh, I was
hoping somebody
would ask that question.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER:
This meeting is just
a phenomenal opportunity to
completely light my career
on fire and in not a good way--
whatever career I have left.
So what's my first instinct?
It's funny.
I was talking to a
reporter yesterday.
And she actually drew a
very interesting distinction
between Twitter and Facebook.
She said, Facebook
is the place I
go to connect with
the people I know,
and Twitter is the place I go to
connect with the people I wish
I knew, which I
thought was interesting
and I think which actually
tells you a little bit.
I think the human
condition is we
want to be connected to
the people that we know.
And I think the size difference
of Facebook and Twitter
tells you exactly how
much passion there
is for connecting
to people that we
wish we know versus people
that we actually do know.
And I think Twitter is in the
purgatory of the in-between,
clearly.
They are neither
Facebook nor Snapchat.
They're not big
enough to be Facebook
and to reap the benefits
of giving advertisers
access to this borderline
infinity of people.
And they're not as narrowly
popular as Snapchat.
And you just never want
to be in the in-between.
And that's really
their challenge.
And I think there were
times in the past where
Twitter, I think, was an
interesting acquisition.
And it's interesting that
those times seem to be gone.
I think there was a time
where Twitter's information
graft, to me, seemed very
interesting to Google,
actually.
But you guys clearly--
I have no idea whether you
ever looked at it seriously.
But you guys clearly
passed on it.
And I don't get a
whiff of interest
from you about that acquisition.
Now maybe you're just waiting
until it's bargain basement
deal.
There was a time when
Facebook felt very threatened
by Twitter, especially by
the very "everything is open"
model.
And that was the
moment when you saw
Mark tweak the privacy knobs
quite a bit on Facebook.
That's when Mark
introduced asynchronous
following on Facebook.
But it was very easy for them
to just on-board those features
into Facebook.
And it obviated the need to
be worried about Twitter.
So it just seems to me
that they're kind of beyond
a pick-up, unless they fall
to a place where somebody just
cannot prevent themselves
from buying them.
These days, Verizon seems
to be in the business
of a big giant
roll-up of everything
not called Google and Facebook.
So who the hell knows?
AUDIENCE: So they never
crossed the chasm?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Well, no,
if you look at the data,
literally they did not,
which is exactly, actually,
the math that I do in the book.
And Snapchat is right in the
process of crossing the chasm.
So Evan's got to really
stay concentrated.
And of course, it
depends a bit also
on how you define
target audience.
If you define target audience
to young millennials and Gen Z,
then Evan is crushing it.
But Twitter, I think,
because it has the aspiration
to broadly serve the internet,
if you look at the numbers,
is exactly in
front of the chasm.
They are one of the great
exact mathematical examples
of what Moore is talking about.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any advice on how
to navigate your career
in the Valley, broken down
into your first 10 years,
your second 10 years?
And what are some of the warning
signs when you say, go run
for the hills?
And what are some
of the signposts
for, all right, let me hop
into this as soon as I can?
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: So my
favorite warning sign for myself
is when I have a moment
during a day where
I have a choice about what
I can do next, as opposed
to 12 things that
absolutely have to happen
and I don't really have
much individual choice--
when in those
moments of choice I
find myself increasingly
doing something
that's not my core job--
and you have to actually
step outside of yourself
and observe yourself doing this.
When you increasingly see
yourself doing something that's
not your core job,
it's probably time
to connect to something else.
Now that might be
at your own company,
because here's something I think
that's under-appreciated by big
companies-- which clearly
Google and Facebook now are--
which is just the sheer number
of variety of opportunities
inside that company without
having to give up the equity
and reputation--
I don't mean equity stock,
but equity reputation
that you've built
at that company.
So when you detect yourself,
in those moments where
you have choice, drifting
to something else,
pay attention to that.
That, to me, has always
been a pretty effective way
to find yourself connected
to what you do best.
And that simply is
going to be when you're
going to be happiest,
you're going
to be working
harder at it, you're
going to produce better
results, you'll be known for it.
For me personally--
you mentioned
do I do 10 years,
10 years, 10 years.
I personally don't
work that way,
but that certainly
doesn't mean that you
shouldn't work that way.
I find Silicon
Valley, the situation,
even at individual companies,
much less the Valley itself--
there is so much opportunity
and constant forward progress
that if you try to
estimate, I'm going
to do this in three,
five, seven, 10, 20 years,
that you'll actually lose
sight of the opportunities
in front of you.
So I have a tendency to
just run a very tight loop
with my career, which
is, find something
that is going to be
awesome at a place
that you think is awesome.
And this book isn't just about
how the hell does Zuck work.
It's also about, how can I
use this for my own career?
Think about what are you
seeing around the corner,
in terms of your own career,
that nobody else is seeing?
And then just kick as
much ass as you possibly
can at that thing.
And then look at
what opportunities
that's created for
you, rinse, and repeat.
And that's a tight loop that I
use for managing my own career.
And then things happen.
I find it's hard for me
to plan three, five, 10,
20 years ahead.
Or to, like, in my
my first 10 years,
I need to do x so that in
my second 20, I can do y,
because I find I do
my best work when
I'm pretty stoked about
that thing that I've picked.
And you can't just pick
something for two months.
Nobody wants somebody that
does this for two months
and then that for two months.
Eventually, your resume
will just look like shit.
So it's a very,
very personal thing.
I hesitate to even give
advice on this topic,
because so many people
do it different ways.
AUDIENCE: So with
Facebook, do you ever
see them coming out with their
own next big product in-house?
Because you see something
like Masquerade pages.
None of those things
really take off.
Most of the things that
they've done, they've acquired.
We've got WhatsApp,
Instagram, and Oculus--
Oculus which is in the News
for all the wrong reasons
right now.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: True.
Absolutely true.
Yeah, that is a
really great question.
And I address it
specifically in the book.
In the book, I have
a whole chapter
that I call "Failure
Isn't," which is just
kind of the standard
treatise on,
you've got to
institutionalize failure.
If you're not
trying enough shit,
not enough good things
will come out of it.
But then the chapter right after
that is when does all this,
quote unquote, "failure"
turn into just failure, which
is what you're talking about.
You kind of now look
at the track record.
You would argue Messenger has
done extremely well, especially
with the arrival
of David Marcus.
That's obviously a
homegrown product.
The thing that we don't
talk about as much
that's also doing
very well homegrown
is Groups, because
it is a separate app.
You may not use it, but 600,
700 million people a month
do use that app
very specifically.
But you're totally right.
The homegrown track record-- not
so good, especially after Zuck
failed twice to
convince Evan to sell.
He then failed
three times trying
to build an app that's like it.
I'll tell you
what's interesting,
though, is starting five years
ago, he picked up Instagram.
Then two years later,
he picked up WhatsApp,
kind of on the back of
picking up Instagram.
Then he picked up
David Marcus, who
used to be the CEO of PayPal
who now works for Mark.
So you can see Mark's pretty
effective at bringing people
to Facebook.
And so now all
the sudden, he has
four tools to compete
against Snapchat with.
And he's actually chosen
the best possible strategy.
If you're fairly ego-less
and you're OK simply copying
the other guy,
then he has chosen
a perfect strategy,
which is like,
congratulations, Evan,
for inventing stories,
I will now build this into
all four of my products,
so we'll see you
on the other side.
And then I'm sorry, then
I'll build an API for camera.
So at some point,
you've got to worry.
Here, to me, is actually
a bigger concern,
which is business at Facebook
going really well, profitable.
He's able to engage in a
bunch of additional things,
like picking up Oculus,
trying to pursue
connecting the unconnected--
all of those kind of things.
And there comes a
point in time where
you're doing too many things.
And suddenly, you have
too many failures.
And you lose track of
how many of these things
actually lead to anything.
You become deeply distracted.
And he's not there yet.
But that's something that
he'll have to monitor.
And that's never
happened to him.
It'll be the first time that
he'll have to deal with the
"when is too many
things, too many things?"
And he's always been
incredibly good at dealing
with the first time
stuff happens to him.
He's one of the
all-time greats at that.
But we'll have to see.
Notice, by the way--
you're totally right
about Oculus, by the way.
That has not gone well
for a bunch of reasons.
And turns out, his execs were--
yikes.
But notice what
he's done to fix it.
And I'm going bring this
back to a Google story.
He went and got
himself Hugo Barra.
Don't underestimate
that shit for a second,
because Hugo was your guy.
And then he went to Xiaomi.
He was huge there.
And now Mark's like,
this Oculus thing--
not going so well, change
the management team.
Hugo, please come
in, run AR/VR for us.
And it's amazing, by
the way, how often--
all the time, he says it 100%.
Whenever Zuck is talking about
Oculus, he's always AR/VR.
So this has nothing to do with
giant-ass ski goggles connected
to PCs.
He is clearly working on this.
And he got himself
Hugo to go do it.
So even though he picked up
Oculus and it didn't work--
which you could
argue was a failure--
he's an interesting
enough place for Hugo
to go to to go fix this thing.
So even his failures are
kind of turning out OK,
because he's got safety nets.
But we'll have to see what
happens the first time he's
really facing a major crisis.
SPEAKER: Mike, thanks
so much for coming.
Great to see you again, man.
Thanks for coming in.
MIKE HOEFFLINGER: Thank
you so much for having me.
I really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thanks, everybody.